dr oz earlier you talked about the blue
zone life that we all aspire to
um when that notion that book um
dan buettner uh came into my world it
was just so eye opening because i really
do believe in the facts
of the numbers and the ages and the
consistency of
people living long healthy lives and we
actually have two
special guests who are doing just that
and they both turn
100 this year wow and
um it's a year in which they also
celebrate 80
years of marriage
welcome to the show live from their own
little blue zone in boca raton florida
lou and edith hi guys
[Applause]
hi lou and edith congratulations on
living a long healthy life and 80 years
together
very lucky people oh yeah very lovely
lou what do you think the secret is to a
long marriage
the main thing is we never went to sleep
angry at each other i remember in
all the years we had our arguments like
other
couples but we never went to sleep yeah
look at that
we never went to sleep angry oh
your photographs we've been marveling
over them
can you tell us in your wise estimation
what is a good key to a long life well
lived
we went to a nutritionist when i retired
and the nutritionist said where do you
live i told them boca west
on the fourth floor she said i'll tell
you what you ought to do
walk up and down once a day try it
and for 35 years we rarely
have used the elevator oh wow i love
that
that's a blue zone secret right you made
the tip part of your life so you do it
every day
that's the key to longevity period i'm
so proud of you guys
totally we're blessed thank you we're
very very lucky
i appreciate it so much
that life has really been good to me it
really
is yeah we're blessed we really are
never 16 years old
that's right that's when you guys met
right but i met him yes
right yeah yeah we we grew up together
and the big thing is at this age we like
each other and that's so
important
thank you lou and edith well
i know that i'm going to be taking a
whole new set of memories
into my future and our future here at
the show
thank you it's been a lot of fun it's
been such a special day we've learned so
much
thank you dr oz everybody tune in to dr
oz show on weekdays nationwide check
your local listing